ثقتي مشيره لهذه المعلومه ربما ااه المهمه
نقنع المراسله الجزيره عائله الفتى محمد
عليوات تم في ان يكون هو منفذ عمليه سلوان
وتقول ان وجوده صادف لحظه الحادث الذي كان
هذا الخبر المتعلق بما نقلته الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه بانفذ العمليه هو الطفل يبلغ
من العمر 13 سنه نتكلم عن نفس الفتى
المعني في الخبرين ان نتكلم عن طفل الاخر
سيد ايهاب
بدايه انولدت جدا لا يمكن نفي حتى مثل هذه
المعلومات لا يمكننا فيها يعني الاعلام
الاسرائيلي دائما يحاول اول
دائما تحاول ان تبحث عن الفاعل وتقول ان
تغذي في الجيش
وليد عمر عن هذا النفي من قبل عائله الفتى
محمد عليوات وليد
الى حد كبير قد يكون صادق لان الطفل في
الثالثه عشر من عمره من اين سياتي بالمسدس
وكيف سيكون قادر على اطلاق النار واصابه
شخصين بالغين في صدريهما هذا العائله
تنفيذ ذلك تقول انه تصادف عبور ابنها من
المكان وانه اصيب من النيران التي اطلقت
شهود العيان افاده بانه بعد اطلاق النيران
من قبل المسلحه الذي اطلق النيران على
البؤره الاستيطانيه واصابه اثنين كان هناك
اطلاق نيران على نطاق واسع وهذه المنطقه
التي وقع فيها الهجوم هي منطقه مقتظه
وفيها حركه متواصله سواء لطلبه المدارس
واحد ايضا فلذلك قد يكون ما قالته العائله
هو الصحيح والسرعه التي تحدثت بها قوات
الاحتلال ومن ثم نقلته الى الاسعاف عادهم
يقتلون من يهاجم لا ينتظرون للتحقيق معهم
طفل في الثالثه عشر من العمر صعب تصديقا
انه يكون قادر على حمل مسدس واطلاق
النيران بهذه السهوله على كل حال الحديث
الذي توارد بعد وقوع العمليه وهو من مصادر
الاسرائيليه بان الفتى 13 عاما نقل الى
الاسعاف وان الشباب اجرى معه تحقيق داخل
سياره الاسعاف قالوا في البدايه ان جراحه
همم خطيره ثم بداوا يتحدثون عن انها حرجه
ولم يوضحوا اي شيء جديد هذا من ناحيه من
ناحيه اخرى همم اجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه
في ظل حاله الحرج التي تواجهها مع الشارع
الاسرائيلي وما مع المستوطنين تحديدا من
ان هناك فشل امني وتقصير كبير رغم كل حاله
الامنيه المستنفره في القدس تقع مثل هذه
الهجمات هي ستحاول ان تظهر بانها القت
القبض وانها قضت على المنفذ باسرع همم ما
يمكن مع العلم بالامس حسب بصير ما جرى في
مذا يعقوب انه لو لم يطلق المهاجم النيران
على الشرطه وهو في طريق خروجه من الحي
الاستيطاني لما عرفت الشرطه انه هو
المهاجم فكيف اليوم ياتون الى طفل
بالثالثه عشر من عمره قد يكون الطفل فعلا
ضحيه وليس له علاقه بكل همم ما جرى هذا
سيتضح لاحقا لكن هم سرعوا او وسائلهم
الاعلاميه سارت الى النقل عن مصادرهم بانه
هو المنفذ في البدايه قالوا انه تم تحيده
في اشاره الى قتله لكن تبين ان الفتى او
الطفل الجريح وانه نقل الى الاسعاف وانهم
قاموا وان الشباب ومحققين المخابرات قاموا
بالتحقيق معه لذا يبقى هناك علامه سؤال
كبيره جدا حوله هويه المنفذ وفيما اذا هذا
الطفل
والفعل كما تقول العائله بانه كان يمر من
المكان